you can't run from your past
[Music]
hi i'm isabella from gate culture how
are you i'm really good i'm really
really good how are you i'm great thank
you
um now shanky is you know he's like a
kung fu expert in this movie and people
have been trying to pull similarities
between him and legends like jackie chan
and don yen and jet li so do these
comparisons keep you up at night do they
keep me up at night
i i would say i would say no because
because i think it's you know in a lot
of ways ridiculous because i i i think
each and every one of those people would
would kick my ass seven ways to sunday
um
you know they're all such incredible
martial artists in their in their own
right and and responsible for some of my
favorite you know
martial arts movies of all time and you
know i think this movie is is in so many
ways an homage to them and and for me as
an actor to be
inhabiting a role that is so martial
arts driven you know very much wasn't
you know like like a jackie or a bruce
or a
jet situation where they were already
you know champion level world-class
martial artist you know i very much was
not
um i was cast for my acting ability and
and for my take on the character and so
you know i knew that i had my work set
out for me i had to train every single
day to get my athleticism and my martial
arts to the level where it could be
you know in brief brief moments captured
on camera and and made to feel like
really really uh skilled
it was a really really humble answer a
really humble answer
oh i can't yeah i would never go up
against jackie or jet i mean those are
my idols for sure
no you had to go against b tony lyon
though he is like an action cinema
legend so how scary or nerve-wracking
was it too
like lay your hands on him how was
rehearsals like uh very very delicate um
i think in the beginning i was so
nervous of a first and foremost hurting
him and be you know making him angry
that i i was i was very tentative and
and
tony is you know wonderful and and
fantastic and has zero ego about him
it's so gentle and soft spoken and
friendly but he said you you can really
hit me you know like you really and i
was like okay tony you know i i i'll try
but even then something in my mind
always stop like i it always just
stopped me i couldn't so like i just
couldn't allow myself to to hit any
harder and i think it's just because i
respect him so much you know and and
he was again very patient such a joy to
work with now you mentioned that you
know
shanghai's kind of in homage to like you
know like the hong kong cinema
and you know
apart from the fact that he's such a
comfort expert he has a lot of heart
he he has a lot of trauma in my opinion
so what were some homework that you did
in order to deliver all this
action and all this like heart that you
had to bring to your character
well you know that that's a wonderful
question and and thank you for for
differentiating those two because i
think shanxi is so much more than just a
martial artist you know he's so much
more than just a fighter i think he's a
really fleshed out character and with
with like you said a lot of trauma in
his life but also a lot of other things
like you know the humor the way that he
is with his best friend katie you know i
think that's what's
part of what makes this character so
unique and so three-dimensional and so
you know obviously there was a physical
preparation that i could talk about the
five six hours a day five days a week
you know stunt training working on
movement and and flexibility and speed
and making sure that i could do all the
action sequences but then there was also
the emotional work of building this
character from the inside out and who he
really is is somebody who
is is hanging on to the trauma of his of
his childhood and you know
even though he wants so desperately to
run away from that and everything to do
with his past and his father
and um and you know that tragedy um you
know he finds himself in in san
francisco where he's kind of just lost
and struggling bearing the weight of his
father's expectations and and struggling
to find out where
where he belongs in all of this and and
so that's something that i mean that i i
have such a
such a deep resonance with because i've
been in that exact same position so it's
really about building out those things
getting really deep into the you know
shared family traumas just the
frustrations and the heartache that we
deal with and within our own families
and and transcribing that into this
character
to give an emotionally true performance
was very important
[Music]
[Music]
you